congratulations you chose the correct  answer D the bungee jumper experiences  maximum acceleration at the very bottom  of the jump this is a counterintuitive  idea for most people because they  confuse the concepts of velocity and  acceleration at the bottom of the jump  the velocity is virtually zero but  acceleration is not so what is  acceleration it is the rate at which  velocity changes over time it is very  difficult for us to spot just by looking  at it because our eyes track motion  smoothly so you have to think about the  velocity at two different times right  before the jumper reached his lowest  point he was going down but after he  reached it he was going up so while he  was right at the bottom his velocity was  changing rapidly in other words while  velocity was minimal it was changing at  the greatest rate the key is to keep the  two ideas separate velocity and the rate  at which it changes